[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen bei Tatort
Deutschland ich bin Toni Heyer und
gemeinsam mit meinem Kollegen Mirko
Kasimir erzählen wir euch jeden Tag
einen Kriminalfall der uns bis heute
fasziniert oder wie im heutigen Fall
fassungslos und schockiert zurücklässt
hey Mirko hallo Toni hallo liebe
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer ja stimmt der
heutige Fall ist einer der
schrecklichsten und unbegreiflichsten
mit denen wir es bisher in dieser Serie
zu tun hatten mit einem Täter der direkt
aus einem schlechten Horrorfilm stammen
könnte ja oder aus Albträumen wir
sprechen heute über den schwarzen Mann
den Masken Mann wir sprechen über einen
Serienkiller über mindestens vier Morde
über Dutzende von Missbrauchstaten an
Kindern an Jungs im Alter von 8 bis 13
Jahren
wir sprechen über eine Serie von
Verbrechen die 20 Jahre dauerte über
einen wahr gewordenen Albtraum der erst
am 15 April 2011 endete und für die
Opfer oder Ihre Angehörigen nie wirklich
vorbei sein wird wir werden euch diese
Geschichte in zwei Teilen
[Musik]
alles beginnt soweit wir wissen am 3
märz 1992 in einem Kinderheim im
niedersächsischen hepstedt ein
maskierter Mann schleicht sich in einen
Schlafsaal der zu diesem Zeitpunkt leer
ist dort wird er von der Begleiterin
einer Schulklasse entdeckt und flieht
durch eine Terrassentür die Kinder ihre
Betreuerin und Betreuer kommen mit dem
Schrecken davon doch dieser Schreck muss
gewaltig gewesen sein wie Horror muss
das bitte für alle gewesen sein auf der
einen Seite die Betreuer also wenn ich
mir vorstelle mir werden Kinder
anvertraut für deren Sicherheit und
Wohlergehen ich verantwortlich bin und
dann sich ein Fremden mit Sturmhaube
über dem Gesicht der sich in einem
Schlafsaal zu schaffen macht und die
Kids vor allem die wollen einfach eine
gute Zeit haben mit ihren Freunden Spaß
haben denken nicht an das Böse und
plötzlich steht da ein vermummter
bedrohlicher Mann also meine Kinderseele
hätte das zutiefst erschüttert doch das
ist nur der Auftakt zu einer
beispiellosen Serie schlagaufschlag geht
es weiter noch im März desselben Jahres
trinkt der Maskenmann erneut in das
Kinderheim ein und versucht einen Jungen
zu missbrauchen als sich das Kind wehrt
flieht er auch im Schullandheim Baden
steht versucht er sich an einem Jungen
zu vergehen muss die Tat jedoch
abbrechen und das Weite suchen in
kluvenhagen ertappt eine Lehrerin den
Täter der einen noch halbschlafenden
Jungen bei sich hat als er entdeckt wird
flieht er und dann nach diesen in
letzter Sekunde vereitelten Taten
verschwindet in der Nacht zum 31 März
1992 der 13-Jährige Stefan aus einem
Internat in Scheeßel am nächsten Morgen
findet man seinen Schlafanzug in einem
Aufenthaltsraum des Internats das
Fenster steht offen
fünf Wochen bleibt das Schicksal des
Schülers ungewiss dann wird seine Leiche
gefunden
vergraben in den pferdener Dünen seine
Hände sind auf dem Rücken gefesselt
Pferden liegt wie Scheeßel in
Niedersachsen beide Orte sind etwa 35
autonomen voneinander entfernt die
Pferden sind ein Naturschutzgebiet im
Stadtpark von Pferden eine der seltenen
inlandsdünen Deutschlands ein sandiges
nur von einigen knochigen Kiefern und
magerem Rasen bewachsenes Gebiet in der
Nähe eines reitweges stoßen zwei
Spaziergängerinnen auf den schrecklichen
Fund die Todesursache steht bald fest
der Junge wurde erwürgt und erstickt das
Opfer kann schnell identifiziert werden
die Ermittlungen scheint schnell voran
zu gehen
die Verdener Kriminalpolizei verfolgt
mehr als 100 Spuren für weitere Hinweise
wird eine Belohnung von 25.000 Mark
ausgesetzt nach wenigen Wochen wird ein
Tatverdächtiger verhaftet ein
23-jähriger Mann bei dem Zeugen die
Geldbörse des Opfers gesehen haben
wollen doch der Verdacht lässt sich
nicht erhalten der junge Mann wird
freigelassen die nächsten Wochen bringen
kaum Fortschritte der Mord wird in
Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst im ZDF und in
fahndungsakte auf Sat.1 dargestellt aber
auch das bringt keine neuen Erkenntnisse
der Vater des getöteten Jungen wirft der
Staatsanwaltschaft Fehler und
Versäumnisse vor und beginnt selbst und
auf eigene Kosten zu ermitteln er steckt
10000 in die Suche er lässt ihn abhoben
untersuchen und engagiert private
Detektive
seine privaten Ermittlungen bringen ihn
schließlich selbst mit dem Gesetz in
Konflikt so verteilt er etwa auf dem
Schulhof des internatsflugblätter auf
denen er den Leiter der Schule und einen
Lehrer der Beteiligung am Mord
beschuldigt
damit ich eines Tages in Frieden sterben
kann muss ich wissen wer das getan hat
erzählt der Jahre später der Täter ist
da noch immer nicht gefasst und der
Maskenmann geht weiter auf die Jagd
zweimal wird der Mann zwischen April und
Juni 1992 im Kinderheim Hettstedt
gesehen bevor er dort in einer August
Nacht mehrere Kinder weg und unsittlich
berührt im September weckt er einen
anderen Jungen und fordert ihn auf sich
auszuziehen in einer weiteren Nacht im
Oktober des selben Jahres und im
gleichen Kinderheim spricht er
nacheinander fünf Kinder an und
missbraucht drei von ihnen
auch das Schullandheim Badenstedt wird
weiter von ihm terrorisiert im August
1992 vergeht er sich auf einer Toilette
an einem zehnjährigen im September trägt
er einen neunjährigen aus seinem Bett in
ein Nebenzimmer und missbraucht ihn im
Mai 1994 wird ein elfjähriger dort
missbraucht ein Jahr später ein
Zehnjähriger im Oktober 1995 muss er
flüchten ein 13-Jähriger wird sich und
weckt andere Kinder im Zimmer als der
Maskierte ihn unsäglich berühren will
auch im Juni 1998 muss er fliehen als er
versucht zwei Jungen zu missbrauchen
auch Zeltlager werden zum Ziel seiner
Übergriffe im August 1992 missbraucht er
zwei Kinder im Zeltlager selcanor in
Schleswig-Holstein im Juli 94 weckt er
sieben Kinder in zwei Zelten in
Otterndorf und belästigt sie sexuell im
selben Sommer werden zwei weitere Jungen
in Selker nur seine Opfer und ich weiß
nicht wie es euch geht aber das Ganze
klingt so unfassbar diese ganze lange
Liste ich frag mich wie ist so eine
Serie überhaupt möglich diese massive
Häufung an Missbrauchsfällen ein Mord
und niemand scheint den Masken man
stoppen zu können heute rückblickend
betrachtet scheint das alles natürlich
auf der Hand zu liegen aber damals sah
die Sache ein bisschen anders aus es gab
hier mehrere Faktoren zum einen dauert
es natürlich die Fälle an verschiedenen
Orten in Zusammenhang zu bringen
wichtig ist aber auch und es ist bitter
das sagen zu müssen dass viele der
Kinder anfangs nicht ernst genommen
werden es klingt aber auch fast wie
ausgedacht beinahe wie eine
Gruselgeschichte am Lagerfeuer ein
maskierter ganz in schwarz gekleideter
Mann der aus dem Dunkel auftaucht
unerkannt verschwindet und kaum Spuren
insbesondere keine sichtbaren
Verletzungen an den Kindern hinterlässt
und es ist ja tatsächlich ein
ungewöhnlicher Fall wir wissen dass die
meisten Missbrauchstaten an Kindern von
Menschen begangen werden die das
Vertrauen der Kinder haben dass deren
Opfern auch viel zu oft nicht geglaubt
wird steht auf einem anderen Blatt aber
ich glaube es spielt doch eine Rolle
dass der Typ so unglaublich dreist war
er scheint kaum Angst vor Entdeckung zu
haben und das obwohl er zu Beginn seiner
grausamen Serie mehr als flüchten musste
auf mich wirkt das als fühle er sich
fast unsichtbar auf so eine ekelhafte
Weise arrogant und überlegen
ich meine er missbraucht seine Opfer in
Zimmern und Zelten die Sie sich mit
anderen Teilen an Orten wo die nächsten
Erwachsenen Betreuer nie weit entfernt
sind vor einem solchen Täter ist
absoluter Schutz nicht zu erreichen wenn
man die Kinder nicht zu Ihrer eigenen
Sicherheit wegsperren oder rund um die
Uhr beobachten möchte naja und gerade in
Zeltlagern und Schullandheim ist ja eine
gewisse Freiheit auch wichtig für die
Kinder wenn ich mich an meine Kindheit
erinnere was wäre das denn für eine
Klassenfahrt gewesen bei dir die ganze
Zeit an Erwachsener im Zimmer gehockt
und uns bewacht hätte unmöglich ja auch
der Mord passt nicht ins Bild meist
steigert sich ein Täter mit der Zeit es
beginnt mit sexuellen Belästigung und
missbraucht der immer schlimmer wird bis
er irgendwann beginnt zu töten hier ist
es aber andersrum der Mord steht am
Anfang
[Musik]
1995 tötet der Maskenmann erneut in der
Nacht auf den 24 Juli verschwindet der
achtjährige Dennis aus dem Zeltlager
Selker Noah zwei Wochen später finden
deutsche Touristen bei Skive in Dänemark
die Leiche des Kindes vergraben in einer
Düne mehr als 250 km vom Zeltlager in
Schleswig-Holstein entfernt
anfangs wird jedoch kein Zusammenhang
zwischen dem Mord an Dennis und dem Mord
an Stefan drei Jahre zuvor hergestellt
mit den Fällen sind unterschiedliche
Polizeidirektionen beschäftigt der
Maskierte hat unterdessen ein neues
Jagdgebiet für sich entdeckt aber april
1994 dringt er in mehrere
Einfamilienhäuser im Raum Bremen ein und
missbraucht Jungen in ihren eigenen
Kinderzimmern an einem Ort an dem Sie zu
Hause sind und sich sicher fühlen und an
dem sie sich nie wieder sicher fühlen
werden
die Vorgehensweise unterscheidet sich
zwar in einigen Details von den Taten in
den Schullandheimen und Zeltlagern
trotzdem geht die Polizei davon aus dass
derselbe Täter dahinter steckt im Herbst
1995 missbrauchte einen Jungen im Haus
von dessen Familie der zehnjährige wird
davon wach dass jemand ihn an der Hose
berührt und an ihm herum spielt
der Täter redet die ganze Zeit auf ihn
ein wiederholt immer dieselben Worte du
brauchst keine Angst zu haben ich tu dir
nichts
das Kind versucht zu schreien doch es
kommt kein Ton über seine Lippen dann
wird die Schwester wach die neben ihm im
Bett schläft und sie schreit der Täter
springt auf und ergreift die Flucht im
lebenzimmer ist die Mutter der beiden
Kinder vom Schrei des Mädchens wach
geworden reißt ihre Tür auf und sieht
noch einen Schatten die Treppe hinab
brennen
als die Polizei am nächsten Tag die
Aussagen aufnimmt behauptet der
zehnjährige die Stimme zu kennen kann
aber nicht einordnen woher
für das Kind wie für alle überlebenden
Opfer des maskierten ist die Sache damit
noch lange nicht ausgestanden der Junge
wird aggressiv und auffällig erst ein
siebeneinhalb monatiger stationärer
Aufenthalt in der Kinder- und
Jugendpsychiatrie hilft ihm mit dem
Erlebten umzugehen
diese Tat im Herbst 1995 wird viele
Jahre später zu Ergreifung des
Verbrechers führen doch noch ist der
maskierte Mann nicht zu fassen
[Musik]
in unserer nächsten Folge erzählen wir
euch vom dritten Mord des Täters und von
einem weiteren Verdächtigen Mordfall
diesmal in Frankreich davon wie der Mann
mit der Maske endlich gefasst wird und
wer sich hinter dieser Maske verbirgt
wir bleiben dran und ihr hoffentlich
auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören eure Toni
und euer merkung den Fall des
maskenmannes haben wir mit Hilfe von
Artikeln der Kreiszeitung Stade Radio
Bremen Weser Kurier Bild und Spiegel
nachher erzählt Redaktion Stefan
Netzeband
Postproduktion durch die Wake Studios